I don't know how I'm gonna survive my mom's pageant season
She already started her diet
Already?
Dumplin', the other side
[Moans]
Okay darlin', just grab my ankles
Uh-huh
Ok
MmmHmm
Oh God
My name is Willadene Dixon
Hey, Willadene
Hi Bo
Most people call me Will
except for my mom, who calls me
Dumplin', I can't be late
This cannot exactly drive itself
Being a bit of a celebrity around here meant that she was too busy for me
You've got a hole in your left by the way
What?
[gasps] This must be your daughter
That's my daugher's best friend
This is my daughter Willadene
Wow, ok
And that's when I decided enough was enough
I know that look
What's going on?
I think I'm gonna sign up for the pageant
It's gonna be like a protest in heels
Willadene Opal
Hey y'all, if you're signing up, I am too
No, I'm not the Joan of Arc of fat girls
This is gonna be so much fun
Totally fun
Pageants are harder than you think
I'm Rosie Dixen's daughter
It runs in my blood
Woo!
We really have to play to our strengths
My strengths are hula hoop, and I can tap dance
[singing]
No no, um, stop it
I think I know where we can get some help
What is this place?
It's the closest thing you can get to Dolly Parton around here
Oh, wow
Dumplin', I don't understand, why are you doing this?
It's a protest
We're trying to make a point
Willadene Dixon
I think you're beautiful
To Hell with anyone else who's ever made you feel less than that
There's nothing in the rules that says big girls need not apply
I've got myself into somethin'
but now I don't know what I'm doin'
You know that Dolly saying?
Figure out who you are, and do it on purpose
Viva la revocion, baby!
That was truly a surprise